[Applause]  you got to move the defender create  space  and that's why you do it here's you guys  shooting three ball  knocks down his first shot of the game a  triple listen to the crowd they are  loving it  book night triple team kickout to ball  misses the three but follows up his  board to the rack  he's just got a nose for the ball  you know good bad and different here we  go ball point six seconds oh we've got  it  at the buzzer  that's what i'm talking about  how you like that centering bert  that was unbelievable  i'm not sure did the clock start that's  the question i'm not sure if it started  but he definitely  [Music]  so they're gonna review the last play  because i think the legends growing  right now the clock unfortunately how  many more followers did he get  i'm not sure the clock start that's the  question i'm not sure if it started  but he definitely